the Joe Rogan experience John Jones
versus Thiago Santos see that anyone oh
that was on steep NDC's design yes I
don't know and Paula Costa is also
rebooked for that that's Anaheim as well
right yeah whoo Yoel Romero Paula Costa
that's body ever fight that's they're
fighting for the best body ever that's
what they're doing but who's the king
did he win some sort of asset yes well
Yoel might never fight again you want
twenty-seven million dollars like I give
up
howdy cuz there's a supplement company
that had tainted supplements
legitimately they tested them
independently and they found out this
[ __ ] is it's tainted and makes people
piss hot for steroid tests hmm so he
sued him the question is whether or not
he's going to be able to correct collect
rather because you know when you sue
someone they can go bankrupt like if
they're a corporation that's why someone
forms an LLC so if they've got some
steroid tainted [ __ ] and an athlete
Susan I wonder if they actually have to
pay or if one that they could just
disband the company cuz 27 million is a
lot of money you know who knows the
company might not even be worth 27
million I don't know what the company is
do you know what the company is what's
the name of it gold gold star
performance mmm that's a big name I've
heard that name before
have you heard that name before I think
that's a big name and supplements you
know a man's anything will blow him up
it'll be worth it just Pam we're gonna
make a hundred million because people
are gonna jump on it you know what I
mean like people don't write
professionally oh [ __ ] we do it yeah
that's true right give me [ __ ] to Hector
Lombard pissed out for yeah 100% that
[ __ ] I got that [ __ ] son you're gonna
get a thick old neck what's up Jamie
they got what if this is the right
company I just looked up when I tried to
type in the revenue they're doing all
right yeah how much they worth I don't
know if this is the right company but
the one I just found says they did I had
a cash balance of 96.5 million as of
December 31st give up 27 million to the
Cuban baby not be the actual same
company but it's got this name at least
I bet it's that company let's say it is
that company come on give up that money
I want to see yo our
just covering first gold chains and [ __ ]
it's living like a pimp well I want to
see y'all romero in like some sort of
crazy gazelle skin coat with like full
six-pack just now minx right makes it be
better like something crazy just 27
million in the bank not giving a [ __ ] 20
girls around yeah just start rapping in
Cuban he's the freakiest athlete I've
ever seen he moves so fast sometimes you
like like what like he you know when he
fought Chris Weidman I remember when he
landed that flying knee I was like oh my
god that guy could do that out of
nowhere out of nowhere you can never
sleep on him because he'll he like lulls
you into this false sense of everything
being okay he moves no you know he just
moves slow moves slow he move away when
you kick them almost like he's
conserving energy and I bet he just
jumps on you it's amazing to see a guy
like him at 40 years of age be that
[ __ ] explosive you know you're right
at 40 with that lawsuit [ __ ]
my wife fight he might go maybe he wants
to [ __ ] up Paulo Costa and that's a wrap
and after that fight but if he actually
gets the money that's the problem see
it's all [ __ ] until the money's in
your bank account because if they appeal
and you know the dragon in two appeals
court which they probably will right
could take years to take yours yeah yeah
then the meanwhile if they have that
money they could just invest that money
and just make itself back and then give
them what they invested with that here
here's your money didn't cross the [ __ ]
they could do that - as long as it's
long enough maybe they have like 500
million 25 million